cual figura coincide con las tres pistas
aquí tenemos tres pistas si queremos
saber cuál de estas figuras de abajo
coincide con estos tres enunciados es
decir cumple con las tres pistas
iniciamos vamos a leer las tres pistas
la primera dice la figura es un
cuadrilátero cuadrilátero que quiere
decir cuatro lados así que observemos
las figuras y veamos cuáles coinciden
con la primera pista entonces veamos
esta primera figura en esta primera
figura hay 12
cuatro lados por lo que si es un
cuadrilátero un cuadrilátero tiene
cuatro lados la figura 2 tiene 1234
lados por lo que también es un
cuadrilátero la tercera figura tiene 1 2
3 4 5 6 lados por lo que esta figura no
es un cuadrilátero como es una figura de
6 lados es un hexágono no un
cuadrilátero y como no cumple con la
primera pista entonces lo podemos
descartar inmediatamente de nuestras
opciones pues si no cumple con una de
las tres opciones no hay manera de que
cumpla con las tres y se requiere que la
figura que buscamos va a cumplir con las
tres ahora finalmente vamos a analizar
esta cuarta figura esta figura tiene
1-2-3-4 lados por lo que también es un
cuadrilátero y bueno ya analizamos en
todas las figuras cuáles cumplen con el
primer punto vemos que tres de ellas
cumplen ser cuadriláteros la primera
figura
y la 4ª cumplen el primer requisito ser
cuadriláteros ahora veamos cuáles de
estas figuras cumplen con la pista
número 2 la pista número 2 hice la
figura no tiene ángulos rectos muy bien
que es un ángulo recto los ángulos
rectos son los ángulos cuya medida es de
90 grados y se miran algo así y se
simboliza de esta manera este cuadrado
nos dice que este es un ángulo recto y
se usó un cuadrado para simbolizar un
ángulo recto porque observa cómo se
forma un cuadrado entre los rayos del
ángulo es decir podemos formar un
cuadrado con la apertura que forman los
rayos así que eso es un ángulo recto y
ahora vamos a analizar las figuras y
veamos cuáles cumplen con la pista
número 2 así que bueno de inmediato en
la figura 1 vemos dos ángulos rectos ahí
están esos cuadrados que se forman entre
los lados
de la figura número 1 y bueno aquí hay
una esquina cuadrada y aquí esta otra
esquina cuadrada por lo que la figura 1
tiene ángulos rectos y la pista 2 dice
que la figura que buscamos no debe tener
ángulos rectos así que podemos descartar
a la figura número 1 ahora vamos con la
figura número 2 vamos a analizar la
puedes ver que la figura número 2 no
tiene ángulos rectos estas esquinas no
son cuadradas así que bueno ésta cumple
con el segundo requerimiento con la
pista número 2 y lo mismo sucede con la
figura número 4 esta tampoco tiene
esquinas cuadradas así que hasta el
momento la figura 2 y la figura 4 son
las que cumplen con las pistas 1 y 2
pero falta la última pista veamos cuál
de estas figuras es la que la cumple muy
bien entonces tenemos dos figuras que
siguen siendo candidatas ambas
ambas son cuadriláteros y ambas no
tienen ángulos rectos
ahora la última pista dice que la figura
que buscamos tiene cuatro lados de igual
longitud
sabemos que que tiene cuatro lados
porque es un cuadrilátero pero
requerimos que los cuatro lados tengan
la misma longitud así que analicemos la
figura número dos parece parece que
estos lados el de arriba y el de abajo
son más cortos que los de los lados
observa
por lo tanto no tiene la misma longitud
en todos los lados así que la tercera
figura no cumple con el tercer requisito
así que bueno queda totalmente
descartada pero hay que asegurarnos de
que la última figura en efecto cumple
con todo lo que se nos pide entonces en
la figura 4 parece que todos sus lados
tienen la misma longitud ajá pero para
estar seguros para estar seguros veamos
estas marcas dibujadas en los lados del
cuadrilátero siempre que veas estas
marcas lo que te dice es que los lados
que tengan la misma marca o el mismo
número de marcas son de la misma
longitud ya puedes ver que los cuatro
lados de esta figura tienen exactamente
una marca por lo que todos sus lados
tienen la misma longitud por lo tanto la
figura 4
la ganadora es la que cumple con los
tres puntos que se piden es un
cuadrilátero no tiene ángulos rectos y
tiene cuatro lados de igual longitud